hello everyone and welcome back to this
week's how America is messing up dragon
ball this week our lucky contestant is
viz the company who handles the Dragon
Ball franchises manga the most recent
Dragon Ball super chapter is out and
wouldn't you know it it's riddled with
creative Liberties that make Goku and Co
just say stuff they don't actually say
the most prominent example here is the
viz translation having beerus not know
that Goku is a father somehow the
original line in japanese is just beerus
forgetting Gohan's name but I guess in
English Canon now beerus has Amnesia
these sorts of things are usually not
insane changes such as we s Gohan and
Piccolo beat cmax and excluding everyone
else as written in the Japanese but it's
just I'm just annoyed that I can't trust
the official translation now I don't
want to have to learn Japanese just to
Read Manga without worrying that viz
made up a line for fun